hey guys it's justine and today is gonna
be kind of a two-part video
i've been traveling for the past month
visiting my family so i haven't been
back
or filmed a video in so long that i'm
confused
on how to do anything like speaking
or unboxing but i think i got this i
think i can remember
and what an exciting way to remember how
to make a youtube video
by unboxing some exciting things from
apple now this
is their new pride watch band and this
is the braided solo loop
it is so beautiful i'm such a huge fan
of all of their pride bands and i just
went through
my apple watch collection and i found
these two from previous years
and i think this is probably one of my
favorites i wore this thing
forever like this is so cool but ever
since the solo braided loops came out
like these are
my favorite i also have one of the
silicone ones which is
beautiful this is i forget what color
this is but
i really like it this is my newest
purchase i also got one
in this mint color to match this iphone
case that i got and i said this was a
two-part video because i'm also going to
unbox my air tags
and this little belkin air tag accessory
that they
uh it was pink so i was like whoa hello
you need to be in my cart immediately
and now it's here so these are the
custom air tags i forget
what engraving i got i think i got a pig
and a poo and a skull and i don't
remember the other one
let's open up the apple watch band first
so that i can put this on my body
oh yeah look at this this is so pretty i
love it i absolutely love it
and i also like that they have the
matching watch faces to go with it
look at that it looks so good i have
very small wrists this is a size 2.
oh yeah that's beautiful i love it love
it love it love it love it love it now
that we have our apple watch all unboxed
now it's time to dive into the apple air
tags so i've been using the air tags for
a few weeks now
and i have some thoughts let's unbox and
then we can chat about them
wait i need to get my apple watch face
and there's the new watch face
to match the band beautiful
here they are the custom air tags
oh a poo a poo
an alien a pig and a skull
those are cute
oh yeah these are super cute so all of
the accessories are kind of interesting
and they're all a little bit bulky so i
was kind of interested to check out this
belkan one
so it has this secure little loop on it
and it's pink
so obviously i had to check it out
so this is kind of a little plastic
little number
i'm gonna put the pig in here because
it's pink
and i like that this has like a little
loop on it
the apple ones kind of have a little
snap on it so my concern while traveling
was that it could easily be like ripped
off or unsnapped it is pretty sturdy
not easily be removed but it's not
like a big challenge so there we go
that's nice i actually really like this
there's been so many cool third-party
accessories that have come out so i'm
definitely looking forward to checking
out a bunch of those whenever
i get a chance but my thoughts on the
air tags after using them for a month
is i really like them i have used them
in several situations
where i needed to find my keys and since
i was traveling i
had left my backpack at my sister's
house and i was able to easily just go
and be like oh
i think i might have left at her house
but i'm not sure checked my phone sure
enough it was there
and then when i traveled back to los
angeles i had
no idea where i put my keys like i
actually authentically
lost my keys and i had put them in my
suitcase
i'm not even sure how it ended up there
because i would never normally check my
keys
i always make sure that i have them on
me so they ended up in my checked bag
and thankfully i was able to
track them and find them easily using
the sound
one of the cool security features to
avoid being tracked
is you'll get a notification if you're
in the vicinity of a tag
that has been inactive for a certain
amount of time and it's really cool that
they do do this
because i feel like that's a huge
privacy concern if someone is able to
slip one of these into your backpack or
into your purse and you don't know it
obviously i have not tested out every
single tracker out there so there are
other options
and i do think that something like this
is very important to have on your items
just in case you do lose them or if
they're stolen but the stolen aspect is
where i feel like
there's a slight downfall to these
because these will alert you if there's
one in your bags so if your
thief in the night has your package or
your bag
they're gonna get a notification that
there's an air tag traveling with them
so they'll be able to easily
get rid of it but on the flip side of
things
if someone is using this with malicious
intent
you will be notified and you'll be able
to easily find that air tag so it is
kind of difficult to figure out like is
this a good thing or is it a bad thing
and while i was home it was crazy
because my mom was like someone's trying
to track me
because she got a notification because i
entered the vicinity
and i was there for a while and my air
tags were present and they were around
her phone
so it was giving her a notification just
in case i had slipped one of these into
her bag
and she was unaware of it so it's really
cool that they do do that she was able
to hit
she was able to just kind of swipe the
notification away and say that it's fine
it's me all as well but it is cool
because it happened very quickly too so
if she was
trying to be tracked by an air tag she
would have been quickly notified
the only problem is i think i
overcompensated for how many of these i
would actually need
because i'm like well really like four
is perfect my backpack
my purse my camera and my keys like
those are
that's pretty much it i did put one in
my suitcase and then i also put one in
another suitcase
so i do feel like there are places that
i can put them so i definitely am
getting use out of them but for the most
part i feel like the four pack is
perfect
i love this little pig it's so cute
well i just wanted to do a quick video
and give you guys an update on
my custom air tags i'm so excited they
did ship a long time ago but since i was
out of town i wasn't here to get them so
i'm very excited to check them out
and i hope that i did an okay job at my
first youtube video back sitting
at the desk thank you guys so much for
watching and thank you again for
supporting my channel and i know i've
been a little bit m.i.a but i have been
traveling and visiting my family so i
will uh hopefully see you guys soon i'm
definitely looking forward to wwdc
so i will see you guys very soon for
that i can't wait
to see what they have to announce super
[Music]
[Applause]
hyped